Ok. Johnny johnny. Chill on. Johnny allen. And i was a co-director of the newman aquarius festival in seventy three.
And by dint of my role as director of the strain in the students.
Since then because she had a pretty chick
and career leading to my current role as a vince manager downing have authority.
Responsible for all of the activities that happen in the outdoor spaces of delhi habit. Yes.
Nieminen the aquarius festival for me came out of the series of strains of things that i'd been involved in
and one fairly important one was the one my one hundred first path either can accept with newman.
And what newman was but for me as a side my early training was in theatre
but i soon sort of became interested in theatre in the widest sense if you like the other in the streets as theatre
and. Environment as theatre. And that led me into doing a series of smaller than syria and iran sydney that.
Festivals but in the context of going up to a country like asians
and exploring the strange environment for me it was a little bit about that it was as a young a stride in that had been
born in the country in the end of the cd. It was partly about rediscovering. Country astray.
And rediscovering the environment
and then with that all of the questions that were being thrown up by environmental damage and environmental pollution.
So the theatre was one significant strand of it. And now the onless what i would call the university culture.
I think that.
I was a student at the university of new south wales
and i think the universities around australia are at that point in time i'm talking now them.
Late sixty's were somewhat interesting. For the main ideas and. You know. Fertile ground. When i think back to.
Many of my contemporaries at university where they've gone since it was an interesting time.
So part of it was that sort of.
University culture at isis i the mechanical side of nimbin for me was it was a job as director of the queries
foundation which is something that you strain in universities and said set up to try and carry cultural. Circuit.
Around the universities in the in the usa leading up to nimbin one part of my job was organizing tours.
Of everyone from. Jeanie lewis to cool. Through to. Various environmental speakers. Ron called the cartoonist.
Felix the original sort of folk musician. A whole series of things.
Designed and way a possible way we took that in the direction of not just entertainment
but in the direction of cultural tourism. I guess you'd call a little. Cultural entrepreneur.
So that was one direction. Was of course. Rock music. In the. Years immediately prior to name and i've been running.
One of sydney's only two rock vein use called the x. Factor which is standing golden straight. And that what the x.
Factor was in those days was a bit of a home
and a breeding ground for an alternative a straining music i mean many of the bands of the day. Would drag it cetera.
In the arts factory and. Probably if it weren't for the factory they would never have existed. And that.
You know some of those people. Like when a guy at your window on. Reasonable.
Skewed you can feel the mainstream figures said to me a lot of it was was this business of running a music venue.
And one that was very much about generating. And the striking and rock scene.
Because it's hard to imagine now an issue.
Lived through it
and can take your mind back to a strategy with the sixty's it's hard to remember just how how american culture was in
those days you didn't listen to you know. Too much astray the music you listen to american music. When you watch t.v..
You watched american t.v.
So i thought of that process for me i was trying to get the to and genuinely strategy and rock music.
Which nasa ames one one one one does now i have a can a for being an issue. But it was an issue. In the sixty's.
And then i guess yeah the strand was.
What i recall in my eyes stays as being called the counterculture which is a phrase that people that use anymore but.
That there was a sane seen sidonie and i think quite a tradition going back to the thirty's
and forty's out of the belly of the culture that was. Was a little bit more adventurous.
Radical imaginative than the mainstream culture.
And is a very different feeling in the cd that as i went back to the wonderful characters of the thirty's all of the
lead of vines in the bay miles. There was a feeling of a radical tradition. And i was very interested in that.
By that but i think that's culture. And peps eisai politics and.
There was a how often the that name and represented the bringing together the. Things.
And then i guess the final one was.
What's become known now as is the alternative of will to have seen a little of the new age movement
or whatever that is that. I think arrived a bit lighter. But there was also a sense that that.
We were in some sort of crisis. I mean if we talk about holds when there are people thought you a little bit mad.
But you know we were talking about those sort of things and we can see. Seriously weighed by them.
And it's same to me and to many other people that i would. With at that time that.
We were in a pretty radical situation we had to investigate some medical attendance and.
To mean what newman threw up was just one of many possible directions
and i don't think we were conceited enough to say that you know. This was the direction. But it did seem that.
That an ace we explored some you know some pretty radical new the patches of new ideas.
That we are probably stuck on a one way trip the pows. Waiting for proof.
So i guess all of those thoughts came together as a background that. That led me into. Dropping out of a.
You know fairly tired career as an a.b.c. Producer. Into this. Somewhat less fashionable of cultural entrepreneur.
And director of the festival. One's always.
In those things one's always a check to buy a range of things some of which is sort of.
In terms of my own involvement in things it's.
Looking back on it it's a little bit hard to discern the forces some of it i think comes down to fairly small
and petty things like you like the people on emma very clearly
when i grew up in a fairly conservative the strained household and. Quickly figured out that.
With the sort of people who were involved in things like the
or in the ads with more interesting than the sort of people that i'd been raised with so i naturally gravitated to that
sort of people.
And that meant hanging around the cross or going or exploring various things that was that was the place to be.
So some of what i was sort of more lurid. Motives.
I think there were intellectual lines too i think that the strategy was coming out of a conservative place will be
happy and. Through the fifty's with sort of the forty's and the strategy was. Sort of the. Gray suited.
Short back and sides sort of society it didn't pay you to be very different. When you paid a price for it.
So i think some of it was you know just the label instinct i guess the.
And i think also there was i was part of the post-war baby the. I really think that.
At that point in time not just myself
but a lot of my contemporaries really felt that we were in a position to change things
and change things we did with for better or worse. Is now open to question. But there was a feeling that.
You know that you could actually stay being.
And you could actually be powerful enough in situations to change the course of events and and. Change the directions.
So that's i think what. What attracted me that that that. Intellectual side of it.
And the challenge and the camaraderie.
Of being with like minded people and that you know they were they were good times. As bad as.
Young generations always fighting the good times
but a lot of it was just making the most of the good times that would be had when we heard. Evolving.
I first of all in the program from named and. I mean i guess. One of the first tenets was that.
What we didn't want to do. We were reacting against a nine hundred seventy one.
Aquarius festival that had been hailed on the.
The a new campus it can but i want to say we were acting against it was actually very good very enjoyable festival.
But it stayed very much in a traditional model.
It was about dance companies on stage and theatre companies and theaters and. Music and holds.
And i think very early in the piece we decided that in terms of the energy that we wanted to put into a festival.
Before that. For the time and the place that that kind of festival. With he wasn't going to be.
What we wanted what we were looking for something which was much more able to live to explore. Wider.
Life styles and wider questions. So i culturally i set out to try a network.
Which is a word that i don't think i used until perhaps years after that.
In my role as cultural director i was constantly travelling i'd be in perth on monday in adelaide on wednesday
and back to back to melbourne on saturday in sydney on monday again and.
Used to travel quite a bit to graham dunstan my co-director i'm up we would often do was say arriving in adelaide for a
weekend and saké let's take af-am books who is even this town that.
We think is actually an interesting thing do or do what whether they run a health food restaurant
or whether they run an alternative newspaper or whether they've got an interesting theatre group doesn't matter.
And we would constantly. Paddies.
I don't quite know how we manage the food and the cooking but forty people would come along.
We'd explain that we were trying to do this gathering that was very much about exploring you
and as a new culture is usually quite a lot of people would get up and sort of.
You know you're still living in the sixty's man then she realized that this doesn't happen anymore and we would leave.
And then all of the forty people would be five people sitting there saying when do we stat. Sounds great.
What we do next. And so slowly we accumulated this sort of you and i some.
Hundreds of people around the country who were interested in the thing and.
Interested to the point of stopping everything else in their lives and making it total commitment. And.
Culturally i was interested in following that through to. You know who were the people who were the instigators.
Whether they were the musicians who were genuinely creating it in strange honor of music.
Whether they were the theatre people who were thinking passed. In for. So there was quiet and. Work there.
And that was by of a national network and an international network. It was national because we would draw.
Off university circuit. Today that would be pretty limited.
Denies days that universities into the cultures of this trade see these pretty deeply sad that the few thousand people
ultimately that were part of that great fight probably did represent an interesting think tank of people in australia.
And then there was an international network which was which would simply.
Come about by every time i heard of some interesting organizational performer overseas that seemed in tune with name
and i would write them a letter of this massive bank of correspondence. Basically again.
Simply saying what we're doing inviting them out of that.
And then sort of you know talking to funding bodies like the straight a cancer let's say to the say what assistance we
could line up. So. And that was all very much on the basis of. What i guess i would call tribal cultures.
Whether they were people coming from tribal cultures such as africa and india that were literally still living.
Samy tribal lifestyle. Or whether it was the tribes of the philly parties and they were from paris they were you know.
Which is part of this global counterculture. But we gradually attracted quite a few people.
Some of whom we actually managed to organize the tickets or phase four
and sort of in a came say me officially others who just had heard about a dinner
and sort of thought it sounded interesting
and i would bit of a loose rein so they started making their way to a strata.
It was actually quite an interesting to me to mean in the three months leading up to me.
They would have been out of that tree. Three five hundred people living up there and working around the clock on.
Building toilets. You know. All can izing food chains and such with id.
Family people going to turn up to the festival in the i mean it could have been sort of in a couple of bass
and it could have been fifty thousand new of us and i one was rolling in advance or sending you know.
The same thing in their entry. All of which made. This trade union students rather nervous.
I think graham and i would say the admin the book probably going to destroy the union forever.
And every time we turn around there be another knife in the backside to speak. But it did give rise to this sort of.
My guess is that something.
Something between ten and fifteen thousand people finally came through
and we did manage to you know to organize the food the food chains in the first state it's safe to say that.
Nobody stabbed nobody died and. It was a fairly interesting gathering. And one where. I think what was unique about it.
And what came out of that whole process as i think everyone approached it not so much in terms of coming to a festival
to be entertained. Everyone to paste it the other way around.
We're coming to make it happen we keep saying this new program you're the program. What are you going to do.
And people came with that attitude. I mean in a remarkable way.
And some people whom we've had long communication with and others we've never heard of i mean this sort of.
Entire kind of ten
or twelve place theater group from new zealand called blurted turned up in this wonderful bus that was the real.
Sort of magical mystery tour and just turned up and said. We're here.
You know we're here where we perform live where we live. So lots of people came in that sort of spirit. Very much.
Remember us using. Using phrases like you know what you eat and whatever the whole the whole line was that.
This is a festival it's about culture in the widest sense. It's not about just. Bans on stages. It's about the.
Create giving space. It's about the after cooking meal it's about all about seeing this.
It was a very remarkable campsite was all i'll say.
Of people camped outside this small isolated country to add with some of the weirdest and most wonderful.
Structures and. Performances there were people in tree. They were people that sort of the. Elaborate.
People had sort of you know. I was in the ground people. And i mean part of the the joy of the thing.
I think was so i was wondering around this. Bit of a magical mystery land of all of these things.
And just in countering.
You really did have the feeling that you didn't need to get to the stage to be entertained hell thing was made the time.
And the fact that there were some people in there who. I mean you know.
An interesting example i think is for the party we've heard about on the grapevine and.
Managed to organize a fee from the astray to cancel lisa.
I think he's the blonde and this generation he was the most extraordinary man in terms of balance
and physical feats that other than it came to the man with a knife.
With
and if it is lighter he was paid a million dollars to walk between the twin towers of the financial district in new york.
And when the festool sidney tried to invite him back to a strategy for the bus
and nine hundred eighty eight they couldn't afford him.
You know they were people of that caliber of people who you know. On a world level i think are remarkable figures.
And then.
You know many people who give up and give a wonderful performance he'd never heard of before and never would again.
All of which i think was manifesting a little bit the spirit at the festival which stayed that sort of you know.
We had it with all of us. I mean we live in a society that makes. Special things about of that. And some people into.
But basically. You know. We're latticed inside where either when the true artist life. Wouldn't mind.
Talking about one more powerful than that of the. Another. And i have a.
I think very interesting perform of that that we invited. And it was again part of this networking process.
Was an amazing african. Musician. Called dollar brand. And the make an ism by which. Dollar arrived to.
That name
and i think was interesting because it says something about this networking process through all ways in different
cities that i mean. We eventually sort of.
Kimi and i had quite a large number of people who weren't on the payroll and had no title
but it was just time to stook that but they were doing was working full time. But. Been investable.
And one of the it was very interesting a south african. Called bastogne.
Who knew african culture fairly well and knew a strategy an alternative culture.
And he was determined to being what he thought was so my significant. Musical figure. Of his country which is.
Dollar brand. We did actually again. Manage to get some assistance of insulation these two very cancel fleece.
And he was the person that yes. It was a nice wonderful blade. I think of traditional african music and modern jazz.
In fact he divided his life between the land. And the new zealand. So again. One of the wonderful examples of of.
Someone who came to the festival. And came uniquely in. Unique way.
And there's just one more i'd like to touch on i mean mine could probably go on for an hour just to me amazing
performance.
Spend up at nieman but this is the one that that i think for me was they spelt the whole thing out of us
and it was a group that arrived very late in the festival and their arrival was. It was way special for me.
There was an incident. Halfway through the festival. Someone was alleged to of been paid ling had drugs into of.
There was a story about rape or whatever all of which ultimately turned out to be fiction. I think.
Spinning off the idea that. Any minute. It happened. Very soon after the election of the with the government.
Coming to power and seventy three. And seventy two sorry. And in the seventy's.
And a spot of that with them government coming to power it had been a pretty strong coalition between the student
movement and the union movement and.
Allowed to be aware of it i think there were a lot of forces they had the per interested in. Nimbin being discredited.
Not for anything that had anything to do with us and what we were doing really. But because of that political context.
I mean for all we could figure out this this surprise. Dragon said was in fact a set up.
But what it resulted in was the twenty first quite coming up from sydney.
The whole of nimbin sort of you know forwarding into sort of. Two armed camps.
Leftist radicals on one side and on the twenty first's squad on the other and then sort of.
Lot of lot of people sitting in the middle saying hang on we messed up and made a tidal wave through it
and leave it to the point where the ad really took our i mean the whole festival became about this incident.
And that was blown out of all proportion.
And i didn't cut quite know what to do about it at the time except to proceed with.
You know trying to bring the last of these these. Which was a group from from india called the bowels of bain goal.
And the bows were quite unique in that. One of the eldest musical traditions on the.
They go back to previous times in india. And.
What they traditionally were leaving galli countryside was the gypsies and the seeds being is even to this day
when the bowels arrive in a village in india and dance tools.
And there's a great paddy's haled neighbor and comes to this and actually seen you. The news of the day.
And this was a tradition that i've gone. You know thousands of these. We had got to the plate for i had.
The most famous by the day. Sitting in calcutta ready to. I managed to raise the face for them to come.
But i had no visas and no way of getting them there and outside in the fields. You know.
I really was at the point where it could have fled into riots. So i hopped on a plane went down to canberra.
But never made him before but sort of. Knocked on the door and. And straight into to visit dr h. C.
Rather remarkable gentleman who had sort of stayed up the straight he counseled and.
Been almost single handedly responsible for post-war reconstruction in the state after the war
and at that stage was head of the reserve bank and a very powerful and influential man in canberra.
So i walked into his office he's sitting up there with this huge absolutely clean mahogany desk
and on the table in they knew who i was but that was all. On the desk in front of a b. Had the local afternoon.
That they had lied that we had something like sort of.
Ten thousand and students riot police beaten and was absolutely sensational a spacer got a name and.
So he just he just looked at me. Looked at the paper. And said what do you want.
And i started to burble out that i've got basics people sitting at home and i'm trying.
So i just picked up the facts and immigration and.
I went back on here plane back than in been managed to get these people into. The name and by the by the next day and.
Coincidentally arrived at the naman festival. At the height of the full moon.
And at the height of all this drama that had been going on
and the first performance was to get up in the eighth the full moon and just seeing this absolutely.
If you've ever heard the music it's some of the most lyrical and beautiful music. You hope to hear. And for.
Me personally it was just a resolution of the whole thing.
And then the next day for whatever reason all of that conflict had been resolved.
We never did actually quite get to the bottom of what the drug bust in the set up was all about
but anyway it all went away.
Paper went back to the same feeling of peace and cooperation
and whatever that the festival had started with then in my mind that.
That magical concert under that full moon with the bowels of bengal will always be one of the things that.
For me personally the festival worthwhile. I guess the other one was finally coming down to sydney and before he left.
Walking between the two pilots of. The sydney. Have a beach.
Illegally i might add while he was doing at their place been down the bottom trying to get the guy with guy wires
and i saying well if you do that will be manslaughter and then saying well.
Since he said if he comes down he's going straight into a paddy wagon. But all that aside.
He did manage to win this being the person that he was the challenge
and having to a strategy was to walk between the parlance of the how to be right around the world.
And in fact i mean the maton chappie. Into it with a vital few weeks i can say.
The spirit of new conquers the spirit of the industrial revolution and. So they were i mean in a way.
I being at that story because it illustrates i think one of the things about the name and that's been forgotten.
Since that name been. Infiltrated in many many different. Name and for me. It was never jest. Never just the place.
Was never just a country town and the south wales and it was never just a festival of.
Fifteen thousand people gathering for ten days from a name and was always at an id and the mint
and a group of friends and many other things.
That grew out of a certain cultural conditioning the strategy that was quite unique was lucky enough to manifest that
and to express it at a time.
And then i think it was and then went again some people remained physically human and made that they heard.
Other people talk that name an experience or camaraderie. Or spirit or whatever you might want to call it.
And took that back to the universities all the health food restaurants all day musical bands or whatever.
And i think for some years they
and there was a certain kind of recognition of people that shape out of that experience
when they would meet there'd be a certain.
Recognition a certain common ground that they had shared this experience that.
It was really a lot more than just a terrible thing is it's become something else now.
I remember that in the few years after the name
and wasn't very respectable i mean the cost of all this kind of tabloid press headlines about the drug raid it said.
It wasn't very respectable and.
My mother i mean i've never used to tell people that i've been involved in a big festival she would always sort of
explain some of the way until the women's weekly started running two page kind of photo stories on alternative
lifestyles of name and. And then my mother suddenly became very interested in telling. When i was in trains that.
You know that. Johnny had been involved in this thing.
So i think it went through many different changes for a long while i mean you know that the sydney morning herald was
running sort of regular features i have to name and walk around the university so it's all kind of.
Discussion of the name and what which said something about the significance that that event
and being in in the lives of lots of people. But it came then in journalistic. I think.
To represent a rather handy shorthand for alternatives hippies drugs all of those things.
So that i think now when im been dragged out sometimes. This is not a light up by this program. But when human is.
Dragged out now it's quite often dragged out as a shorthand for first a certain set of things.
Which is not a fait a name of a fate of the things that it represented. Because as i say i think that.
To really try and add up what newman was to say many different people would be very i mean i live.
Very closely through the whole thing and i couldn't easily put into words what newman was the you know he's now.
And once you try and reduce those scenes to sort of tabloid simplicity.
You either missed the point or you simplify the point. Beyond recognition. But.
I think the thing that came out of it for me was that it was a gathering that brought together a lot of creative
and important strands and then at the other end. By the same strains way out again. But they went out.
Reinvigorated and strengthened by the sort of dialogue and. The sort of prices that newman was.
So in many ways it was it was what one would hype. A festival a celebration. Is in a society and. For me personally.
That's what i picked up on. I mean. The last twenty years for me as being not spent being an alternative.
Society person or whatever name and the last twenty years for me it's been exploring that potential.
What is the role of celebration. What is the role of. Community events.
Leading into what i now do which is a manager for hybrid seed new running.
Hundreds of projects a year and doing a festival every weekend.
And looking back i have in my life i've been in the been a few experiences that i've had that.
That's that sort of social process that. That was named and i think the bicentenary in the strategy was one quote.
Very different of it. A different involvement very different coloring. But i think that.
You can almost talk about the strategy before the bicentenary in a straight after the bus and train me.
In terms of what that means is a bit of a cultural watershed in terms of a straight his identity.
And in terms of the way we. We think about time and i think that.
And just as it's taken decades to work out and human and will take many more.
I think it'll take a couple of decades to work out.
The vice internet think all the talk now all of the strategy of becoming a republican the increased awareness of
aboriginal culture
and how white australia sits with its its that so its aboriginal past its i think goal of bias things out.
Top and possehl and. And that's what i what i what i what i mean by.
Celebration and celebration has or has in my mind always i have a tie and it's about very date.
Currents and cultural thinking. And society at my appeared to be just about. Lots of people sort of you know.
Going out in one day and having a good time. But if it's genuine celebration.
To me it's a very profound thing that has all the waves of change and. Always reflections to it is.
It's interesting to think back and speculate on where way society's got to when people die and use the fry.
For example have been hood fyi is the price cap the culture or even alternative society too much anymore and i think.
What's tended to happen is as a lot of the insights of that period. That they'd taken on board. By the why the society.
I mentioned earlier for example that. Nine hundred seventy.
To talk about how to talk about the greenhouse effect at such and the for many years said been. And scientists.
And environmentalist who are aware of all those things and. You know that certain levels of common knowledge.
But in terms of the population in general.
If you talk about those things you're either mad or you have complete medical.
It's been interesting to say what's happened in the last twenty years i mean society has absorbed so many of their sins
they've absorbed the straight mole.
I think people now realize that it's not complete madness to talk about greenhouse effect that's it for the something
that could be very real and could be just around the corner. And people of all sides sort of. Absorbed.
Some of the solutions and i think that.
Right across the board i think the environment has a place in papal sinking now which.
Radically different to that which you did twenty years ago.
And that is reflected as it has to be in very sort of fire and life style wise
and environment isn't isn't just about sort of. The make it picture.
It's about what you do with the rubbish and you recycle things and. What you do with your life.
And if it's not probably in trouble. I mean i remember. We were leaving.
Leaving new york on one visit to new york in this wonderful piece of graffiti. Outside kennedy airport.
Just as i was leaving new york that said. A college the last fad. And that scared me.
I mean if if if if we do manage to let these things like ecology
and the environment etc remain just kind of fashionable fête issues then. The future is very bleak indeed.
So i think that society is.
It has absorbed nice to that sings the question i think that we're all trying to resolve is that once absorbed.
It's absorbed all those things are there any solutions you know.
Can we arrive at a sustainable future and solve some of that sings. The dilemmas are enormous.
I mean i think we've got one part of the industrial first world sort of you know busily now trying to i'm trying to
shed some. Worst excesses and with the same time we've got many parts of the third world desperate.
To do all that consuming that there will always been the not so you've got the current scouting in both directions at
once. And the problems are enormous at the same time.
I think human ingenuity is enormous and i mean some of my from that time. And i think always will remain.
The buckminster fuller's and people like that who take all that on board and set up their ass. Solutions.
It's a question of us becoming an awful and thoughtful and i have to work that's true. And i don't know i mean.
I think i probably see it on a little bit of the fence with all of that where we can debate another twenty.
Is whether we can do it with some of the racing strudel whether we're going to keep.
Plunging headlong down to oblivion. I don't think anyone can say. I think we all know.
I would put the issues that we love. But some of the choices but it's not simple.
It's tempting to sit back and say well you know. Finally i give you the family people would do blah blah blah.
That's not the way works. It's going to be a sort of a long and and and and the sly with the gradual working through.
So many of the signs of positives that the problems and the moments and.
I don't think it will be in my lifetime that we reach a resolution of that i think that it's something that will carry
well into the twenty first century and. Another generation will be grappling with the long before. Long after a.
Shuffled off to a more peaceful existence somewhere else. In terms of have that sort of celebration.
And impulsive and in the news. Has made its way into. The larger population i think it's easy to concede a again.
An issue. Believe through and remember accurately the strategy of the fifty's.
It is fairly hard to realize the difference between the looseness and the freedom in the collar
and whatever the existing nasa citing now that the didn't twenty and thirty six i mean even just i mean but
when you saw right. When you saw a mile in a colorful shit. It was unusual and you turned and looked twice.
Now you walk through any any sort of.
Any shop in town and the sort of you know about that whole area of design and whatever's influenced out.
Fashions and i had to live to an extraordinary extent.
And to an extent that's mainly positive it's also influenced i think very much.
Our ability to celebrate and thoughts and celebration i think it's. It's so loose a culture. One of the things that.
But that i've always been deeply involved in is that we live in a you're paying what was a european cultural outpost in
southeast asia. And what we did in the first century in trade court is whatever it was was. Simply import your pain.
Culture into a striving in that largely into a culture that we have of concert halls
and theaters it's which are something that was devised in the european environment and came out of that environment
and suited that environment. We live in a color climate of course you want to go indoors.
I think the challenge in a strategy is to develop a culture that comes out of this giant which is a type a different
one where a much warmer subtropical. Culture.
We have very much an outdoor culture so the sort of the sort of cultural experiences and events.
Sort of always interested in aptos celebrations and outdoor events. For two reasons first of all i think that sort of.
He's much more explorative of the strategy and. Condition and it's much more you know. What's unique about australia.
And say can be because i can be more sociable.
I think that people do touch shoulders in the hundreds and in the absence of a valuable events and.
I don't think i'm a line in that i think that they are right across the street in society this being in the.
In that direction. I mean the whole. There's a whole. Of instant celebrations movement.
Industry in australia now that it wasn't. Twenty six. I mean they couldn't have been a bison tainui again.
And that's changed i think the way people act when i'm out of a vote the way they think.
Again it's one of these things that you've got to take along to ask why. Why are people wanting his experiences.
And how is it changing the nature of the culture. And i think there are pros and cons to it i think that.
Increasingly we exist in a culture way and i spadeful. That we like to their neighbors or even their families.
Perhaps as much as they did.
Twenty and thirty years ago we tend to see it in a room
and spend many hours a day watching this little square box called television. And we relate to the world. Very much.
Electronically and. The motive. And if you get to los angeles you'll see this taken to extremes.
And i think that's produced a civilization where people just don't touch. One another in flesh and blood.
Much the way they used to.
When the cultural of the way into the way was going out to a movie theater or at least rubbing shoulders in the crowd.
Well going out to the saturday night dance. We do believe in a more kind of. Technologically isolated and.
Boxed in sort of society. And i think that. One of the responses to. That is paying for people to want.
The experience of going out and being part of a large crowds.
I think that if we could shoot fifty years into the future somewhere into the sort of you know.
The year two thousand and forty or whatever and look back on the eighty's and ninety's i think the the unique
and the important cultural events will be that it's mass. People against it so all the sort of you know.
The ly concepts and. Bicentenary s. and Little ships so well by scenes i think cite something about.
This period in time and what's unique about the culture of this period of time. I guess.
I mean i tend to think about a lot about that because that's the look i do. I'm involved by choice in creating.
Community celebrations and whether that's a celebration for fifty or two hundred people
or whether that's a celebration for a hundred thousand people to me making these and. The ones the sign.
But i do observe that that.
You know that people seem to want that experience effect that you can get one hundred thousand people to come out for
and strike a diet dialing or whatever it is says something about the need for that.
And so i think says says a lot about where we're trying to find. Tribal society again.
Some of us are finding it by going off and living in small groups an alternative.
Situation some of us of finding it by living inside the wider than dice culture but trying to find ways of.
Great connecting. By celebrations. And i'm glad we're doing it that way because it strikes me that time.
Societies and the same to break down the lies beyond reason
and work together in a hugely cooperative way for one of two reasons. That happens and warren's response to the threat.
And it happens in pace time when there is a cause for celebration.
And i know which one of those motivations i've done the work of. If you had to try and sum up the queries festival.
Deals behind that. I'd say that. The first one was probably the exploration of alternatives. The feeling that.
That we would be ching danes
and that in a state of in a state of crisis such as i think would probably be a name of subjugating for saddam get used
to it now. It's society in a state of environmental crisis and social crisis in many ways. I think at that is times.
The thing that you do is explore right joel tennant of something you find new ways and talk with us.
So i think in terms of the spirit of nimbin the thing which would stand up for me most would be that that a lot of
exploring alternatives with us as i said with a kind of cultural tenant of soul or building alternatives
or food alternatives or. Healing alternatives it doesn't matter.
And sort of you know approach to that was a very very wide one. They were and they needed lines.
It wasn't about this new religion or theory or that line it was just about exploring alternatives
and was about the to explore the whole. Then the second one would be and they sound like funny words now because like.
When that itself to be and i have a used to say many times that that the woods had to know what the words. Now mean.
But there was a very tangible. Spirit of cooperation and brotherhood.
Togetherness they with name
and that certainly being fairly unique to me i haven't experienced that many times in my life
and i've never experienced it as strongly. History that experience. Why that should be sad.
I'm not quite sure but i think it has a lot to do with when people are working together.
Toward some sort of common cause and that.
It does create a real brotherhood it creates an intellectual affinity and it creates a sort of national input thing
and well if i sings that. Coming out in words like pace and love.
But actually manifest themselves in situations that work. And.
And then i guess the third one to me would be a sort of a cultural cultural dimension that i think.
Did find new ways in terms of a straight in culture. In many different directions and by culture i do mean.
Fairly widely and. I'm talking about sort of you know. Music and theater and i'm also talking much more widely.
I'm talking about the sort of the way. Culture manifests itself. Right across our lives in sort of you know.
In how we light. We dress how we build our hands.
I think that to me it was a cultural watershed is the way in which i could express that it probably was a little bit
the culmination all of in many ways alignment happened in seventy three in many ways it sort of belongs in the sixty's.
Of some of the critics were right. But in many ways it was kind of brought i think to a head.
That price war straight in period where. I think that.
After the war that people didn't have much choice but to put their heads down and rebuild. And it did sort of you know.
Create a very conservative period and i think. Newman was a bit of a watershed where that came to an end.
And it read a bit of a why it has to do with the baby boom
and all that sort of things as well read a bit of a life that i think he can talk about before and even then and and.
And allow it's very hard to put into words i think that there was a certain sort of cultural change that around the
type that had to do with the with the government coming to power. Many other elias as well but i think from.
Around that point. The strategy started. To see itself. By a thin. Much more in terms of a straggling culture.
And what that means in terms of. You know. Data and identity expressed through. Films. Music books.
Social logical thought.
And also one that we're still working through
and my the year two thousand may be significant our place in southeast asia. That all our history was sad of.
Pain cultural up. Areality was that. Significant impact of southeast asia. And i think that sort of enough.
From that time onwards and that but didn't bring that about.
But name them was writing a way that was about those sort of issues and a very sort of.
Broad cultural change which will continue on in my further type of simply declare a republican a straight year in
and the first of january of two thousand i think be a suitable time. To put a full stop to that sad story and say ok.
New millenium. New place in the world.
I don't know whether they'll ever be another name in a way to be another name but. I mean it's quite interesting.
I think that the celebrations of the.